PETE LEPAGE: I'm going to do a
quick intro of our panelists,
and then I will hand it over.
Sitting right here
we have Mairead--
MAIREAD BUCHAN: Buchan.
PETE LEPAGE: Buchan.
So I've messed her name up
probably five times already,
and I've known her for
about four minutes.
So I apologize.
Boris Smus from Google.
We've got Francois Daoust, and
then Matt Caruana, who is
going to come and do
our first intro.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: So I'm
going to start by talking
about something really simple.
It's just text input, which is
probably one of the most
fundamental kinds of
input on the web.
I just think that there are a
lot of lessons to be learned
here because obviously, we've
been using this kind of input
for a long time, longer than
we've had touch or
anything like that.
So we've gone quite far toward
standardizing it.
And in the beginning, there
were really only low-level
events like keydown, keypress,
keyup, that are very tied to
the hardware.
In a way, because of that,
they're really good.
They allow us to attach special
functionality to key
combinations in web apps that
should support where users
need to be able to do
things quickly.
The problem is that they're not
really suited to form- and
text-based inputs.
They're too hardware specific.
For a start, they have a lot of
problems, for example, with
non-Latin keyboards.
Like the Chinese keyboard,
pressing the character key for
man, for example, results in
a keydown event with one
character, which is an accented
a and the keyup event
with the actual character
itself.
So it's difficult to
tell what the user
actually wanted to input.
Key events aren't just really
difficult to use.
There are many kinds of text
input that they just aren't
designed to handle.
And really, it's a mistake
to assume that text input
involves a keyboard.
Speech dictation and drag
and drop can also be
used to input text.
The keyboard on Android has a
microphone button on the side,
for example, which you can just
press to dictate text
into an input fields.
Thankfully, no one has attempted
to write a speech
dictation to keypress
event polyfill.
Instead, there's another event
that we can use, which is the
input events.
It's been recently standardized
in HTML5, and
it's now supported by
all major browsers.
So this makes it really easy to
detect input in a hardware
agnostic way.
Key events are just a bit too
low level for most kinds of
text input.
We don't really want to listen
for physical key presses.
Really, we just want
to grab input.
And the input event is a whole
different way of about
thinking about this.
We stop thinking in terms of
hardware and start thinking in
terms of intent.
We just don't really care about
the hardware at all.
That really, I think, makes much
more sense than listening
for key events.
So why didn't we take the
lessons from text input and
apply them to other forms
of input, like
pointing and touching?
So take the anchor
tag, for example.
It can be clicked,
touched, tabbed.
Do we really want to know
if the user clicked
it or touched it?
Most of the time we don't.
We just want to know if
the user wanted to
navigate to that link.
There are fundamental problems
with listening only for click
events on anchor tags.
What if the user tabbed
to the link and then
pressed the Enter key?
Or what if the user issued a
voice command intending to
navigate to that link?
Perhaps we can just have an
activate event that we can
just use to listen for
the intent itself.
This can apply to command
elements, buttons, as well as
anchor tags.
But at the same time,
pointer events are
still really useful.
They're ideal in 2D drawing
applications, and developers
will rely on them to define
custom gestures for their
applications.
So those gestures can come from
a trackpad, a touchscreen
device, a Kinect, or a
Leap Motion device
used in a 2D context.
To ask a common question, can
touch events coexist with
pointer events?
Yes.
Should they?
Perhaps not.
It's unlikely that a developer
would want to capture touch
events as a subset of
pointer events.
If you have access to pointer
events, it's probably best
just to use those.
Besides, the pointer-type
attributes of a pointer event
gives you access to the input
device type, whether it's a
mouse, pen, or touch.
The same point on coexistence
goes for click events.
Sorry, I've gone too far.
In fact, developers will
eventually get to abandon
click events completely, and
they'll be replaced by more
semantically correct and
hardware-agnostic events in
the cases that they're now most
frequently used, like
anchor tags and buttons.
Libraries, like pointer.js for
example, already make it
possible to move away from click
events and move towards
pointers, which are
more abstract.
The trouble is that almost
all forms of inputs we've
discussed so far involve
input in a 2D space.
Take Leap Motion's JavaScript
API for example.
You can receive input as
an array of hands.
And they can be anything from
zero to infinity, really,
because it depends--
if you have multiple Leap Motion
devices, you can just
have an infinite amount
of hands.
And each hand has coordinates
on x, y, and z.
And how do we turn these
into pointers?
Pointers don't really give us
a z-axis, but it shouldn't
really be that difficult to
add it to the standard.
Hands from Leap Motion can fit
into the pointer event spec.
But at the same time--
sorry.
Just a second.
So another big issue is
standardizing gestures.
There isn't really much going on
in this respect with specs.
The closest we've come, really,
toward standardizing
gestures is in the UI event
spec, which gives us a way to
separate the actual method of
input or the physical action
that the user made
from the intent.
So, for example, we can take a
physical push action and turn
it into an activate intent for
a link, which gives us a more
abstract way of dealing
with input.
Taking a swipe gesture, for
example, on a trackpad, in the
UI event spec gives us a way to
turn this into a pan event.
So it doesn't matter whether
the user provided the input
using the speech API, say, as
go left command, as a verbal
command, or by swiping their
hand on a touchscreen or by
just moving your hand in the air
to mimic a swipe action.
The spec gives us a way to
translate this into a pan
event, which we can then use
to move a page around.
Really in conclusion, we want
developers to produce more
adaptive web apps.
To do that, we need to
standardize input methods.
We need browsers to
support pointers.
And it would also help if
we standardize gestures.
But at the same time, a probably
more future-proof way
is by providing developers with
more abstract ways of
dealing with the actions that
the user intends, like
activate actions for links, say,
or panning actions for
moving a page around.
And that will just make our
life a whole lot easier.
Instead of requiring every
developer to listen for all
these different kinds of events,
for all different
kinds of input methods, we can
just listen for one event,
which is the intent,
and support that.
That's it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So while I'm unlocking my
computer so I can have a look
at the questions,
I know the first
question that's on there.
And it's by far the most popular
question, is what are
the new input types that really,
as developers, we need
to start thinking about today?
And what are the implications
of using those?
So I'd like to hear from all of
you guys what you sort of
think is the biggest and most
important one and what
developers need to think.
So, Mairead, do you
want to go ahead?
MAIREAD BUCHAN: Well, in terms
of the biggest at the moment,
I think in terms of something
that's not just keyboard or
mouse, is touch.
That the majority of your users
are going to have that.
If you're talking about things
that you haven't really
thought of that are coming in,
maybe motion sensing, so maybe
Leap Motion because that's
coming next.
It should be released at the end
of this month allegedly.
But also like [INAUDIBLE] did
loads of work into how many
children are actually using
games consoles, so anything
that you can interact with a
games console with, and also
hybrid mobiles that are games
console devices and mobiles.
So they have joysticks and
touchscreens and maybe keyboards.
So you've got to think about
what application you're making
and what that your users
are likely to be using.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Boris?
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, I would
basically agree with that.
Touch is, realistically
speaking, the only interesting
new mode, at least from the
perspective of what we need to
do as web developers.
But there's a whole slew of
emerging technology that--
I don't think Leap is
at all like the
extent of what's coming.
There's a whole number of--
pretty much every large
corporation has some finger in
this pie of camera-based or
something like this input
technologies, whether it's
tracking fingers,
hands, bodies,
faces, irises, et cetera.
So there's a whole number of
primitives in the real world
that are going to start
to be tracked.
And this is obviously a little
further out, but still
interesting.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: So just to
maybe add something more on
top of the huge list you
already mentioned.
Maybe at the intent level that
Pete mentioned, I would
perhaps add presence or user
attention as a possible way
for a more immersive
experience.
For instance, if you have a
screen that is displayed on a
wall, a mirror, or something,
something that is connected,
you might just want to know
whether the user is in front
of it or whether it's not.
And the thing that you're
going to display, the
interaction with the user, will
change based on that.
Again, it's at the intent level,
so you don't need to
know how the system knows
that the user is there.
They already have some
mechanisms to do that with the
RFID, with NFC, with, actually,
the user manually
entering his status on Skype
or whatever saying, I'm
available, I'm busy,
I'm not there.
So it has [? fallback, ?]
and that could be a new kind of
a user input coming in the
near future.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: I think
that one of the most
interesting developments in
input is speech, because it
forces us to think of input
in a whole new way.
We suddenly have to deal with a
method of input that doesn't
involve fingers, doesn't
involve hands, doesn't
touching, moving, or
anything like that.
So we just have to completely
change the way that we think
about input and write
applications
in different ways.
The first step is to probably
change standards or develop
new standards to allow
developers to more easily
support this new form of inputs
without relying on polyfills.
I tend to think that providing
polyfills is probably a good
way of getting started.
We can produce the polyfill, get
developers to start using
it, and then eventually the
standard will come later.
PETE LEPAGE: Actually, that's
a great sort of segue to the
next question that Andrew
had put in.
And his question was, if
we use a mechanism for
abstracting all directional
input into pointer events,
will we ultimately regret
that decision?
I believe there's a pointer
event polyfill library you can
start playing with today.
But are we regret that decision
in 6 months, 12
months, maybe in 60 months?
BORIS SMUS: I'll take
a stab at this.
So I think that there's some
kinds of directional input
that makes sense to try to
abstract as a pointer and
other things it totally
does not.
Things that are screen based is
an obvious fit, where you
have a natural mapping to
screen coordinates.
This includes mouse and touch.
But when you're talking about
things like Leap or any sort
of sensing in the real world, I
think you quickly fall into
this weird place where
it's unclear what the
client x is, really.
And at that point, you're
dealing with physical units if
you have some z-coordinates,
and you're just
polluting the space.
I feel like it's a
perilous path.
So I guess the short
answer, depends.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Anybody--
MAIREAD BUCHAN: Your only other
choice is coding every
single aspect from scratch.
And is your project going
to be profitable?
Have you really got the
development time to do
pointers and touch and click and
keyboard, which I reckon
probably most web developers
are failing at already.
Like we're not even doing
keyboard and click that well.
So are you going to add another
interaction paradigm
into your development
lifecycle?
PETE LEPAGE: But isn't the point
of pointer events that
you can sort of reduce the touch
and the mouse and all
that kind of stuff to
one simple place?
MAIREAD BUCHAN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I think it's a great idea,
and I agree with Matt.
You've got to abstract it.
Otherwise, we're entering
a world of pain.
You've got to.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
I think abstracting is
important, but you still need
to retain the ability of
distinguishing between these
different types of input.
Like for example, you often do
want to have a touch-specific
thing, which pointer events do
let you do because you can
distinguish between [INAUDIBLE]
and touch.
But that's an important thing
to carry over so that we're
still able to do these sorts
of customizations.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: Yeah.
So just to complete, again,
there are different layers or
different levels.
And you want both of them--
maybe there's more than two,
but you want actually the
intent level for generic
interaction, and you want the
more precise level, the pointer
level, being one, the
touch level being a
deeper one, maybe.
All of them have some use cases
that need to be fulfilled.
So the difficulty is teaching
the developer what to use and
how not to misuse, because if
you mix the levels, you're
going to end up breaking your
app pretty quickly, I suppose.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And I think we've all seen lots
of apps that have gotten
a little bit broken with touch
and that kind of thing.
Well, let's go--
all right.
Go ahead.
BORIS SMUS: A question for
people in the audience.
How many of you actually know
what pointer events are?
Just curious.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
BORIS SMUS: OK.
So we actually are talking about
something that half the
people don't seem to
know what it is.
OK.
Cool.
So maybe just a quick intro
to pointer events.
Basically--
PETE LEPAGE: 30 seconds.
BORIS SMUS: Pointer events is a
way to consolidate mouse and
touch input into one type
of event system.
The reason for this is touch
events and mouse events are
basically two completely
separate systems.
There's this weird synthetic
event concept where mouse
events are generated for touch
on mobile devices.
So if you don't have a
touch handler, you
still get mouse events.
But this leads to a whole
bunch of problems.
So, anyway, now that we're
on the same page,
another quick question.
How many of you actually have
touch-specific handlers in
your applications?
OK.
So maybe about half.
Sounds good.
Thanks.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Mairead, I wanted to go
to your question next.
Do you think that devices lying
about the event they are
sending, ie, touch devices
sending fake clicks, motion
sensors that likely motion
faking a touch event, is
unhelpful and somewhat
reminiscent of browsers lying
about their user agent?
MAIREAD BUCHAN: So to kind of
clarify this, well, I was
looking at the Leap Motion.
And what it does is
it projects a 2D
plane in front of you.
And when you touch that
plane, it sends
that as a touch event.
So anything you've built to be
touch related, Leap Motion can
do in 3D by pretending
it has a 2D surface.
If you look at how a touchscreen
pretends that it's
had a click, and that doesn't
really work, is the Leap
Motion touch really going
to be the same as
you touching a surface?
It's not, is it?
So the more we end up
down this dark path.
And also, if you're doing
feature detection, are you a
touch device?
Yes, I am.
No, it's not.
It's something else lying that
it's a touch device.
So that's dangerous ground, I
think, because, what, are you
going to go back to user agent
sniffing because your feature
detection is not working?
I don't know what's the
answer to that.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: One of
the problems that we have
right now, in fact, is devices
that support multiple input
types, like laptops with screens
which you can touch,
for example, but which also
have a mouse connected.
In the FD web app, we use a
library called FT Scroller.
But the issue that we have with
scrolling right now is
that we feature detect first
if the browser supports
pointers, then if it supports
touches, and then obviously
will fall back to
mouse events.
The problem with that is that
we sacrifice usability.
After we successfully feature
detect touch events, it means
that user won't be able to use
the mouse, for example, to
scroll a layer.
We should really be able to just
use pointer events, and
it should work for all the
different inputs, for the
mouse or for the touchscreen
itself.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
So on that point, I think for
the case of a touch laptop,
it's important not to
just ignore mouse.
Maybe the best practice is to
prevent default on such events
as opposed to not listening to
mouse events at all, since you
can no longer assume that
touch implies not mouse.
And on the question of reducing
different kinds of
input to different other kinds
of input, I agree with you.
It's a dangerous path.
Just like reducing touch to
mouse didn't work, reducing a
Leap, which actually tracks--
it's a sausage tracker,
essentially, tracks sausages
in the air--
reducing that into a touchscreen
also doesn't work.
And it's an insult to what
Leap can do, just like
reducing a touchscreen to a
mouse basically eliminates any
possibility of multitouch.
We have completely unexplored
territory in the 3D tracking
space that we would just
lose entirely.
PETE LEPAGE: I want to dive a
little bit deeper into the
interactions when using both
touch and mouse because,
Boris, you showed me a couple
of demos yesterday where
having an object on screen, you
can put your finger on it,
and then use the touchpad or
your mouse to make it move.
I think there are a lot
of really interesting
opportunities there that
haven't been explored.
Let's talk about some of
those different ones
for a minute or so.
BORIS SMUS: OK.
So I guess there's a
couple things that
are interesting here.
So the first one is just the
transition between the two
modes, in like a Windows 8
touch laptop, seems like
there's some opportunity
to have some--
almost like a responsive
input-type approach, where
instead of adapting to
screen size, you're
adapting to input method.
Just kind of throwing
this idea out there.
I haven't seen anyone do it
well, but it's interesting.
The other angle is multiple
inputs simultaneously.
So like what Pete was
describing, with a trackpad
and a simultaneous touchscreen
interaction.
Again, I've built some
prototypes around this stuff,
but it's pretty early.
And I think it'd be cool to see
more of them from other
people and have a discussion
about them, but it's a little
too early, I think,
to really go into.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Fair answer.
Anybody else have any
thoughts on that?
All right.
So the next question we have,
tapping links on a page incurs
a 300 millisecond delay to work
out if the user is doing
a double tap to zoom.
Can we get rid of this
delay somehow
without losing the zoom?
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: In
maintaining FastClick, which
is a polyfill that we developed
at the FT to get rid
of the delay, we've dealt
with a lot of issues.
[? You will ?]
constantly bring up the issue
that we've effectively
disabled zooming by firing a
click event as soon as the
finger leaves the screen,
as soon as the touch
end event is fired.
The issue seems to be that
really, we can't have the best
of both worlds at the moment
without an API that we can use
to zoom the page when we
detect a second tap.
But even in that case, really,
because once the finger has
left the screen, then you've
already fired the click event.
So we haven't figured out a
way yet to get the both of
both worlds.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: I guess,
unfortunately, the double tap
thing is really at the operating
system level.
It's something that
the device brings.
And you cannot just prevent it
from happening within a web
app, within a web browser,
within this device, without--
we can't even imagine, I guess,
an API that would allow
the web app to prevent the
double tap, because it's a
usability feature.
It has also accessibility
implications.
I guess the answer for me is,
no, you cannot right now.
New devices will probably
improve the touch interaction
and maybe remove
the double tap.
I don't know.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: Do you
that if we're building
responsive layouts, then the
users shouldn't really have to
zoom in the first place?
FRANCOIS DAOUST: Well, no,
but I know that the--
I believe that they should be
able to zoom in, but I know
that it can trigger a lot
analyst discussions on who's
right and who's wrong.
So I'm more--
it's the same thing with
the meta viewport
when you disable scaling.
It's the same discussion
somehow.
And in my view, it's supposed
to be the user choosing
whether he wants to
zoom in o or.
He may have good reasons
to do that.
But on mobile devices or tablet
devices, it's hard to
find another interaction that
could be used to zoom in.
So you're kind of stuck.
So when you develop web apps for
customers, for instance,
you will have to make
some workarounds.
And you will disable zoom in,
even if you don't want to,
just because otherwise,
the web app is
not responsive enough.
BORIS SMUS: So we've had lots
of discussions about this
particular thing.
And I think this is an
optimization that's either in
the Chrome beta for Android
or coming soon.
Basically, if you have a
non-user-scalable page,
there's no reason to have this
click delay, so we just
disable it.
Basically, I think this is the
way that things should be, and
FastClick is a giant hack that
should never have existed.
I'm not saying it's
like a bad thing.
Clearly, there was a--
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA:
I agree completely.
BORIS SMUS: There was a
need for it when there
was a need for it.
But it's time to get past that
and fix our browsers.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: I agree.
MAIREAD BUCHAN: I don't know.
Why would you loading a page?
Or can you guarantee that when
a pages is loaded that it's
going to be zoom disabled?
Do you see what I mean?
Like even if you've made a
responsive mobile site, a user
still might want to zoom
in on something.
Can you ever really make
a web page that's--
BORIS SMUS: I would argue that
yes, because if you look at
native apps, basically--
if we look at the extreme of
adapting content to your
device, then in the ideal case,
we should be doing this.
I don't think it's
unreasonable for special cases.
I'm not saying disable pinch
zooming in general or double
tap to zoom, but I
think there are
cases where it's justified.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: If we
have a pinch event, then
really, we could just listen for
that and zoom when we get
that event, rather than
using double tap or
anything like that.
And pinch makes sense because
you can theoretically pinch
with your hands if you're using
a Leap Motion device.
So it makes sense as an
abstract gesture.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So as you guys were talking
about that, I wrote down one
off-the-cuff idea is, why can't
we just put an attribute
on elements and say, this
element, if the user double
taps on it, anything in here,
we don't get a zoom.
And then you can just say,
all right, great.
Everything in here, if the user
touches on it, that's an
immediate click.
BORIS SMUS: Great idea.
Microsoft implemented it in
IE 10, or maybe IE 9.
There's a CSS property called
ms-touch-action, I think, and
you can configure exactly what
happens when you touch this
particular element
to the extent of
disabling particular gestures.
So you can say no scrolling
on this thing, or no pinch
zooming on it.
And I think it would be great
to standardize this sort of
thing, just because declarative
things are kind of
better from many perspectives.
So, yeah, that's
my perspective.
PETE LEPAGE: Do you know
where it is in the
standardization process?
Or is it even there?
BORIS SMUS: As far as I know,
it's not anywhere.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
All right.
BORIS SMUS: But I
could be wrong.
Rick?
RICK BYERS: I'm Rick Byers.
I'm the Google person on the
Pointer Events Working Group.
And so the question was the
ability to disable double tap
to zoom with touch
action, right?
So touch action, as we
standardize it right now, has
pan, none, and auto-- pan-x,
pan-y, none, and auto.
And double tap isn't in there,
in particular because to talk
about zooming individual
elements only makes sense in
IE's concept of content zoomable
where you can have an
element that's independently
zoomable from
the rest of the page.
And so we debated adding some
notion of zoom-to-touch
action, but without a notion
of content zoomable, it
doesn't make any sense.
All that really makes sense
is the page itself
being zoomable or not.
So far, in Chrome desktop, for
example, we don't have any
zooming at all.
We're not going to add double
tap, because there's no way in
hell we want to add that
300 millisecond
delay in Chrome desktop.
And in Android, it's
the viewport tag to
disable double tap.
That's where we are right now.
But I think we'll--
we've got to figure out how
can we not delay the click
while still permitting some--
certainly pinch, we should still
permit without disabling
double tap.
So I think maybe adding
something to touch action is
appropriate or some
other mechanism.
PETE LEPAGE: Anybody?
MAIREAD BUCHAN: I kind of feel
like, why don't we just ditch
double tap?
Like, is it really that
much of a win?
If you can pitch to zoom, do
you need two ways to zoom?
Not really.
Let's just filter that
out, fix that.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Anybody have anything else they
want to add on that one?
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA:
Just that I agree.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
What do you guys think?
Should just everybody take
away double tap to zoom?
AUDIENCE: No.
PETE LEPAGE: No.
All right.
Well, there we go.
So it seems that the panelists
disagree with you.
Jake?
Can we get a mic?
AUDIENCE: So it's quite often
if I load a page on my phone
that's not optimized for the
screen size-- it doesn't have
a viewport metatag--
I'll quite often do the double
tap thing, right, to bring the
paragraph to full width
so I can read it.
But there's probably some way
that we can do around that.
If it does have a viewport tag,
but it isn't fixed zoom,
when the user starts the
interaction we know that
double tap's going to have no
effect because the paragraph
is already full width.
And then we could take
the shortcut there.
We would assume that
one tap is click.
We don't wait 300 milliseconds,
because double
tap is probably not what
they're going to do.
AUDIENCE: And there are also
some touch devices that it
doesn't implement multitouch.
So with the single input, the
double tap solves the problem.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: That's
one point I
wanted to raise as well.
When we talk about input, we
are actually entering a
wonderful world of patents
and that kind of stuff.
And it makes it hard, actually,
to be able to do
whatever you want.
And so indeed, the pinch
couldn't be done in previous
version, at least of other
mobile devices, because of
obvious patents--
or maybe not obvious, actually--
but anyway, because
of patents.
So there's always this side of
the story that we don't like
to talk about and that we don't
like as developers but
that still exists
in this world.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
But I think that's--
hello.
Test.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: [INAUDIBLE].
BORIS SMUS: Sure.
That said, I think as
developers, there's nothing
that prevents us from
implementing.
[LAUGHTER]
PETE LEPAGE: So obviously,
the audio gods don't
want Boris to speak.
There we go.
All right.
Let's try this again.
BORIS SMUS: So I think the
patents don't affect insomuch
as web developers as
we can implement
our own gesture handlers.
They're just not going to
be available natively in
platforms for any foreseeable
future.
But we can still make our own
gesture libraries, and there's
many of them out there.
So that shouldn't
be stopping any
development in this direction.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: What it stops
usually is standardization.
It's where things stop.
And gestures have been stopped
for that precise reason, at
W3C, at least.
There are other examples.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Anything else?
All right.
Let's pop down to the
next question.
This is one that I added because
I think it's a really
important question that
gets addressed.
As web developers, how can we
test our sites if we don't own
a touch PC or a touch
laptop, right?
How can we be testing our sites
to see how they're going
to interact on some
of these things?
Obviously, going down to the
local computer store and
testing your web app on there
and then going home isn't
going to work.
MAIREAD BUCHAN: Well, in my
experience, the only way to
develop, to test on a device
is to have in your hand.
And if you really can't afford
to that, then I think you need
to get testing labs or these
kind of browser shop places
where you've got someone
else doing it
with an actual device.
I haven't found any emulator or
simulator that was really
that useful.
And even if you're looking at
something on a screen, and
you've got an iPad-shaped thing,
like our designers were
designing things.
And then when the QA actually
had an iPad in his hand, his
thumb, the way he was holding
the device, actually obscured
part of the design, which you
can't mimic unless you're
really holding an
actual thing.
I think if you can't afford
every device, and if you're a
sole trader, there's no
way you could do that.
You're going to have to
put an extra line
item in your budget.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: Yeah.
Well, I'm afraid there's not
many other solutions.
We do a lot of development on
connected TVs, for instance.
And you try the emulators.
They just don't work as the
actual TV, so you really have
no other choice than to have the
set-top box, the TV, the
whatever in your room
and try it.
You can just delay the time at
which you start to try to test
the app on a natural device,
but it has to be done,
unfortunately.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: At the FT
we use a testing framework
called eggPlant to test using
the iOS simulator, and it
seems to work quite well.
It's just very difficult to get
using, because you have to
learn their scripting language,
script the device.
It's very labor intensive.
BORIS SMUS: I think it's worth
mentioning that the simplest
thing you can do, if you're
especially a content-oriented
site, is you can enable
touch events in the
Chrome Developer Tools.
So it's just a tick box
in the settings.
And if your site doesn't work
with that enabled-- basically,
what it does is it creates a
touch-equivalent event for
each mouse event.
And if your site doesn't work
there, then it's not
guaranteed--
or basically, if it doesn't work
there, it's guaranteed
not to work on a
mobile device.
So you don't have the opposite
guarantee, but
it's at least something.
The other thing is I would--
pardon my shameless plug, but
basically, there's a GitHub
repo that lets you take your
multitouch trackpad on your
Mac device and just essentially
pass those events
into the browser, synthesizing
multitouch events.
If you want to check it out,
it's called MagicTouch, and
it'll work on your Mac.
End of plug.
BORIS SMUS: Rick.
PETE LEPAGE: Mic coming
up behind you.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA:
Behind you.
RICK BYERS: There's just one
more really important piece I
think I just wanted to mention,
that for this common
case that Matt was discussing
about a site that when you run
it on a computer with
touch and mouse,
the mouse stops working.
That's the case we see all
the time in Chrome on
touch-enabled laptops.
That's actually really
easy to test.
You can run Chrome with the
flag, dash, dash, touch
events, colon, enable.
From about:flags, you
can turn that on.
We really would like to
have Chrome always
support touch events.
The problem is, people conflate
the idea "does the
browser support touch events"
with "is there a touchscreen
attached?"
And in theory, we want the
browser to always support
touch events, because you
could plug in a USB
touchscreen any time.
And we can't just suddenly start
have [? window down ?]
on touch.
We can't change whether or not
the browser supports touch
events during the lifetime
of a renderer process.
We can only do it on startup.
It would confuse the page,
even if we could do.
So we'd love to be able
to just say-- in
fact, we've done it.
I think for Chrome 22
for a while, we
supported touch events.
Everyone complained that
sites were broken.
I'm like, yeah, it's because
they assume that supporting
touch events means that there's
touchscreen attached
when it doesn't.
So please, turn that flag on.
Run with it on all the time.
It doesn't hurt anything except
it might break your
site because you've got
bugs in your site.
BORIS SMUS: So actually
on that, it's sort
of interesting when--
I think we're getting to a place
where there's a lot of
possible permutations of
input that's available.
And there's no real
way to know what's
actually hooked up.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm the only one that's
kind of hit this, but it seems
like sort of a bigger issue
for the web platform.
Just--
yeah, no real point here.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Anything else we want
to add to this?
All right.
Let's pop down to the
next question.
And I think it's actually going
back to the sort of
standardization comments we've
had a couple of times.
But should we started working
on this standardizing of
spatial and gestural input from
the upcoming wave of 3D
motion sensing devices
like Leap Motion?
MAIREAD BUCHAN: And so I was
talking to a research
department at Kingston
University, and they deal with
human-computer interaction.
So they've been working with
multimillion pound software
and hardware to do human pose
and gesture detection.
And they've written a couple
of EU standards for gesture
and also human body pose.
So that kind of research has
already existed, not in the
web development world but
in the HCI world, for
quite a long time.
If I was going to see a standard
for us to work with
Leap and Kinect, I would like
it to be following in the
paths of other people's
research.
I don't want to reinvent the
wheel for that kind of thing.
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA:
I agree with that.
For most use cases, developers
will just want to listen to
the intent.
For example, in the few use
cases right now where a Leap
Motion device is attached, we
just want our website to
continue working if we're
listening for
events on links, say.
But for applications that
specifically target--
meant to be used with Leap
Motion devices or the Kinect,
say, then really need a standard
way of dealing with
input from these devices.
The market is probably
going to grow.
There are going to be
many new devices.
We can't just ship all the
different JavaScript libraries
for every single device
with our application.
It's just not scalable.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
I would sort of agree
in spirit with the
standardization idea, but I
really do think it's early
days for these kinds
of inputs.
And I think before standardizing
it, it's
worthwhile just to let a million
flowers bloom and just
to see what the commonalities
are and what the useful things
are for standardization before
we move in that path, because
it's going to slow us down.
PETE LEPAGE: Matt, I want to
go back on the same path of
something that you said that
kind of jogged my mind and I
thought was kind
of interesting.
Should we maybe think about with
the PointerEvents spec
just adding a z-coordinate
to it?
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: Yeah.
I think that make sense.
Why not, really?
PETE LEPAGE: Would something
like that work for Leap and
all of these other things,
potentially?
MATT CARUANA GALIZIA: It would
work in a limited sense.
It wouldn't allow you to make
the best use of the Leap
Motion device.
But for doing basic things, like
manipulating something,
let's say a graphic within a
3D plane, then that works.
For more complex gestures, then
of course, it will be a
bit more difficult to use
pointers in that sense.
You'd need something a bit
more sophisticated.
MAIREAD BUCHAN: I think the way
I see it, there's a couple
of different kinds of
applications that you might
want to use, a 3D motion-sensor
device and the internet.
So one kind of use case is that
you're building a website
that someone's going
to browse.
So they're swiping carousels,
and they're
scrolling the page.
And that's quite traditional
web development.
Or there's another aspect
where you might be doing
something more in a 3D
environment, so gaming and
things where you need inertia
and speed and like also, 3D
motion does kind of tilt,
and rotation of a point.
So it's not just x, y, z.
There's actually a lot of other
information, and that's
relevant to a 3D world.
But it's not really relevant to
someone browsing a web page
or reading a magazine
on their television.
So what kind of application
you're developing, it depends
how much information you need.
So pointer is really good for
websites, and there's other
things that would be relevant
for other kinds.
BORIS SMUS: I agree.
And I would actually be wary
of adding a z-coordinate to
pointer events, partly just
because it's unclear what the
units would be for
all this stuff.
You're breaking the connection
of a mapping-to-a-screen
coordinate.
As soon as you're dealing with
tracking real world stuff,
it's in some different
coordinate systems that's
basically--
if you can bring it back to
screen space, you're doing it
with some weird transform.
But there's some other
set of coordinates.
Typically for a depth cam, it's
x, y, z, in millimeters,
which would be very confusing to
suddenly change your units
to millimeters in
pointer spec.
So my vote for keeping
pointers clean.
PETE LEPAGE: Francois, do you
want to weigh in on that one?
FRANCOIS DAOUST: [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
All right.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So pop down to our
next question.
What will be the equivalent
event for hover mouseover for
touch devices?
Should we abandon the
hover event when
considering touch devices?
FRANCOIS DAOUST: I guess that
could happen in the future.
You can already do that, some
kind of presence detection of
the finger, with several
systems, infrared or--
what's it's called?
Ultrasound.
There are some systems that
allow you to detect the
presence of a finger without
actually touching the screen.
But it has more limited use than
hover, and it's supposed
that the user is not shaking and
is actually pointing his
finger correctly.
We should not close the door
to that possibility, but I
don't think that's a main
use case right now.
BORIS SMUS: I think it's
important that we don't rely
on hover for just the general
web, again, because of mixed
modalities, possibly of input.
If you rely on hover, generally
touch devices are
not going to be able to
see whatever's there.
It's a very clunky interaction
to have this.
You can activate the hover
state, the CSS hover state, by
doing this weird action.
You press down on the link, and
then you move away from it
before it long presses, or
something like that.
And then you get the
hover state.
But obviously this is not
something that we want to do
or have people do.
So I do think that
it's important.
Though there's technology coming
to make this happen,
it's not going to
happen tomorrow.
You should be very aware of
hover states in touch and
don't do it.
PETE LEPAGE: There
a comment back--
AUDIENCE: Actually, I
ask a question, yes.
And the reason I ask is, so my
wife has a Samsung Note, which
comes with a pen.
Because it comes with pen, pen
can do the kind of hover
equivalent.
When it comes too close to the
surface, it mimics hover.
And also, when you do a drawing
in something like
Wacom they also have
the hover.
And it's very critical,
especially when you start
doing [? data ?] visualization
or something, you don't want
to touch everything, because
you just want to glance the
information.
Then you need a [INAUDIBLE]
information, which I don't
want to touch everything.
So I think hover is kind of
getting neglected, especially
in the touch.
You think a touch panel
enhances the input--
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --but it's actually
one [? other ?]
thing.
It's decreasing.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think that's a really
valid point.
MAIREAD BUCHAN: I think it's
kind of highlighting the
problem of like a kind of--
I don't want to use the word
"semantics," but I can't think
of anything better--
like a hover with a mouse on
a 2D screen is not really a
hover at all.
That's a mouse entering
a bounded area.
It's not hovering just above it
because you've only got two
dimensions.
What's a hover in a 3D world
is different to a
hover in a 2D world.
And actually, it should be
pointer Enter before pointer
is activated.
And your active is your click,
and your Enter is your hover.
But we need to move away from
that kind of terminology,
because it is confusing.
It's a mixed metaphor.
I like hover, but I tell my
designers they're not allowed
to use it anymore.
PETE LEPAGE: We've
got time for, I
think, one more question.
So we'll go for this last one.
Smooth scrolling is critical
for a good touchscreen
experience.
What are some of the common
pitfalls for introducing
scroll jank to touch input?
BORIS SMUS: So one of the common
things people tend to
do is do a bunch of stuff
in their input handlers.
So this breaks down really
quickly with multitouch,
because you're having your
touch move events firing
basically at a rate proportional
to the number of
fingers on your screen.
So you end up having
a flood of--
I don't know-- something
like--
I've seen it go up to, like,
200 fps touch input events.
So if you're trying to render
at 200 fps, you're obviously
going to be throttling your
rendering engine.
The workaround to this is use
RequestAnimationFrame, set
state in your input handler, and
then render on render as
opposed to on input.
PETE LEPAGE: Anybody else
got anything they
want to add to that?
Who's there?
RICK BYERS: Rick.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Can we get a mic over
there real quick.
RICK BYERS: I'm sorry.
This is such a big problem I
can't help not speak up again.
I think people often don't
realize the implication of
putting a touch handler
on your page.
So if you're using touch events,
the model is that the
browser can't decide whether
or not to scroll until it's
dispatched the touch
starter-touch move event to
you and waited to see if
you're going to call
preventDefault.
And if you preventDefault on the
touch starter-touch move,
that means you're canceling
the scroll.
You might even be in the middle
of the scroll, and you
preventDefault to move, and it
means we have to cancel the
scroll, which means in modern
browsers, we try to do as much
scrolling as possible
on the GPU thread.
Which means we've got to block
the GPU thread, synchronize
with the main thread that might
be in the middle of
JavaScript or loading a page to
wait to see what your touch
handler is going to do
before we can go
back and undo scrolling.
And it's a huge problem.
So the key guidance
I would give is--
what we've done in the recent
versions of Chrome and what
iOS does is it's got region
tracking so that the GPU
thread knows which regions
of the page have a
touch handler on it.
So if you confine your touch
handlers to just the elements
that really need to have touch
handlers, then we can only
introduce the jank when
you touch those.
If you put a touch-move handler
on your document, it
means that every single scroll
has got a block on the main
thread, and it's going to be
almost impossible to have
smooth scrolling.
This is one of the things I
think is a problem with the
touch event model.
Pointer event solves this.
PETE LEPAGE: There's a
comment back there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It was just related to
what you were saying.
How does that translate
through to clicks?
Is it just touch, or what
happens when you've got the
simulated clicks from the touch
events with scrolling?
PETE LEPAGE: Sorry.
Just to make sure
I understand.
What happens when you have
simulated clicks?
AUDIENCE: So if you've got a
click handler element that
you're using to scroll, does
exactly the same thing apply,
or it just--
RICK BYERS: It's just touch
handlers, because click is
triggered by a tap gesture, and
so there's no ambiguity
between scrolling and tapping.
So you can have a tap handler,
you can have
a mouse-down handler.
In theory, mouse wheel
has the same problem.
In theory, mouse wheels are
blocked on JavaScript.
If there's a JavaScript
handler, we have to.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]--
RICK BYERS: --all browser
implementations
today always block.
They don't do the region
tracking for mouse wheel,
because there's a psychological
effect.
Scrolling with your finger, you
really notice the jank.
Scrolling with your mouse wheel
or the trackpad, you
don't notice it so much
because you're
not physically connected.
So in theory, the problem exists
for mouse wheel, and we
said we're probably going to
apply the same region tracking
we've done for touch to
mouse wheel in Chrome.
We just haven't done it yet,
because it's not as important
because of that psychological
effect.
FRANCOIS DAOUST: I know the
discussion has focused on
touch, and the question
mentioned touch explicitly,
which I just wanted to open it
to another dimension, which is
just a regular nav-down,
nav-right, nav-left, nav-up
events, which are the ones that
you'll receive when the
user is using a TV remote,
for instance, on a TV.
And it makes scrolling,
actually, a bit of a pain
because you have to handle it
yourself in the web app with
the nav-down.
And you have to, well, scroll
the viewport, obviously, and
then also handle links
in the good old days.
But the TV is kind of huge
screen, as opposed to the
mobile of 2000, where you had
the keypad, but you had the
small screen, so it was kind
of easy to make the
navigation.
So anyway, I just wanted
to raise the point.
Do not forget that there's more
than touch and mouse.
PETE LEPAGE: I think that's a
great point, and I think the
performance tip there of really
making sure that you're
being aware of where you're
putting your touch events,
listeners, and all that stuff
is a really great
point to end on.
I want to thank the panelists
for joining us up on stage.
I hope you guys learned
something, and it was quite
interesting for you.
And go build cool.